I also have this uh video that
I've had for a couple of days maybe
you've seen it circulating I I just
think it's it's pretty extraordinary and
it's a great lesson for all of us
this is a self-described quote-unquote
non-binary tick-tocker who came out as
non-binary to her family
and yet has found that her grandmother
is not going along with it so granny
ain't having it basically uh the tick
tocker then reads a letter that her
grandma wrote to her which we're
supposed to see the letter is like
horrible and bigoted was actually one of
the best examples of real maternal love
that
I've heard in quite some time so I want
to go ahead and play that for here it is
hi so recently I texted my parents
because I'm gonna go home for Christmas
and I said hey
do you mind calling me Mike when I come
back for Christmas
and then when I got home today I got
this letter from my grandma and it is
addressed to miss oldname
not actually
but you know I don't want to say my real
name on the Internet
Dearest
dead name on this our blessed mothers
feast day I am writing to tell you that
I will not address you as Mike my
decision is probably not a surprise to
you Others May comply with your request
my anguish in your chosen name and what
that means has to do with your Eternal
Soul know that I love you more than
words could ever possibly convey to you
no matter how you decide to identify
yourself does not change my deep love
for you honey
because of my concerns for your soul and
your mental health I am spending more
time with Jesus's adoration the my
cousin's last names are doing the same
for you
um then she lists my one two three four
five cousins that are below the age of
ten who are apparently
um offering up special personal
sacrifices for me who I didn't tell
um that I wanted to go by Mike I didn't
want to
I haven't talked with your godmother and
her family but I'm sure they would do
the same for you do you know how much
your cherished and loved it would be a
joy to see you and be with you during
the coming Christmas
um a celebration of our Lord's birth
uh
that is what
what love sounds like that is true
maternal and Christian love that's
exactly what it sounds like from the
grandmother
and this fits right into the theme of
the show today I guess about being uh
direct to the point and being honest and
truthful and that's exactly what this
grandmother is doing for her
granddaughter something that um from the
sound of it seems like most people in
her life are not willing to do and this
young lady is
um going to be very upset
because she wants to engage in something
self-destructive and she wants people to
cooperate with her delusion and right
now she is guarding that delusion
jealously because she sees it as uh she
sees it she wants it to be her identity
and she sees it as her salvation you
know whatever she's trying to escape she
sees this as the way to escape it and so
anyway doesn't go along with it she's
going to lash out and uh and be very
angry and sad about it
but what we can hope and pray is that
and I think that there's a good chance
of this that uh as this young lady grows
up
eventually she's going and this might
happen
when the grandmother is dead you know
this might this might be after the grid
this might be years later after the
grandmother has always has gone on to
her reward but uh there will come a time
I believe and hope when she will look
back and realize
that her grandmother was perhaps the
only person in her life who really loved
her
um
and this that's what this love does it's
like this great the grandmother
obviously wants a relationship with her
grandchild obviously loves her obviously
wants to get along with her wants to see
her and wants wants everything to be
happy and fine
but she's willing to sacrifice that for
the time being for the sake of
uh her grandchild's mental physical and
spiritual well-being in the long run
and she's even willing
because this grandmother obviously knows
what's going on it's very intelligent
person and so she knows that there's a
possibility
that this could sever the relationship
for the rest of the grandmother's life
and so if the time ever comes when that
love really sinks in and and and this
the the girl has it Awakening
the grandmother might not even be around
to see it
but this is the Legacy that she's
leaving behind she is sacrificing
something in the moment
for the sake of
the girls uh
you know ultimate betterment and for her
salvation
that's that's what that's what love is
that's what it sounds like
um
it's no different than if
you know you're on a ship at Sea with
someone and uh let's say the grandmother
maybe the grandmother and the grandchild
are on a cruise together and uh and the
the girl says that you know she
identifies
suddenly as a dolphin and so she's gonna
jump into the ocean and you know she's
gonna jump into the middle of the sea
and swim like a dolphin you know
the most loving response obviously no
matter how much the girl believes that
about herself no matter how much she
wants to be seen as a sea creature no
matter how much she wants to be seen
that way it's not true and so if the
grandmother goes along with it all she's
doing is condemning this child to to
drown in the depths of the ocean as she
jumps in and uh and drowns
it's like in the so is that love
to condemn someone to sink into the dark
depths of the ocean and die is that is
that what love is
but that is exactly what many people are
doing to to kids in the name of
so-called love condemning them to
sink into the darkness and despair and
drown and die
if you really love someone and you
really care you're going to be willing
to tell them the truth
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block um
if you're not a member yet you become a
member and use code Walsh at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
see over the members block if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you